[Music]
there apparently is also
a shortage of room demosphere in nevada
and it's the story the i-team first
broke last month
about the drug that's used to treat
patients with copin 19 who are
hospitalized with respiratory issues
the i-team's vanessa murphy has new
information on the state's struggle to
make sure
patients here who need the drug get it
a family member of a patient with
covid19
reached out to me saying their loved one
needed remdesseviere and it took calling
the pharmacy board after seeing our
story
to facilitate getting the drug to that
patient
the nevada pharmacy board is
coordinating if one hospital needs
remdevier and another hospital has it
they try to transport the drug to the
patient immediately
here's what president donald trump said
about ramdesevere monday
last week we distributed 2979 cases of
remdisservier which
is proving to be extremely powerful and
good
enough to treat more than 19 000
patients had great results this
includes 500 cases for florida 500 for
texas 300 for california 200 for ohio
and 150 for arizona and georgia
and those numbers will be going up
rapidly as we move along
on monday i asked the executive
secretary for the nevada pharmacy board
how many cases nevada is expected to get
in its next
shipment he told me 19
while the state of nevada has requested
in his words
thousands and thousands he also insists
if a patient in nevada needs remdesphere
the patient will get it again it just
may take some work
after the i-team first reported this
information in july
a family member of another patient
reached out saying the patient needed
the drug
hospital staff at st rose said it wasn't
available
in that case the eye team called the
pharmacy board and then the drug
was delivered to the patient we checked
in with saint rose again
tuesday a spokesman says all patients
who need it are getting it
as we've reported a spokeswoman for
governor steve sisilak told us on july
23
the governor asked vice president mike
pence for an increase in the allotment
of rem de severe for nevada
but right now it is unclear why the
shipments of ram deserve to nevada
are seemingly small i've reached out to
fema to try to get answers
vanessa murphy 8 news now now you can
find more information like the
fda stands on rimdemosphere and the
i-team's previous stories on that drug
at 8newsnow.com